mónica Adama everyone could use someone
like you in their life but if they're
not coachable or they're not a good
teammate then they cause problems and
it's it's just not worth it you push
your - your team to the limit and you
expect nothing short of perfection
that's probably why the Navarro cheer
team has won the NCAA college nationals
a whopping 13 times you're quick to kick
athletes off the team when they
disrespect your rules but it's nothing
personal you just want what's best for
your team not the individual you might
come off as cutthroat to those who don't
know you but your cheerleaders love and
respect you and that's all that matters
winning the NCAA college nationals in
Daytona is the epitome of success for a
cheerleader but to win the title you
first need to make it to the mat and
let's just say that making it to the
competition and actually competing are
two very different things
keep watching to find out which rule
prevents half the squad from performing
their routine in front of the judges how
are we gonna set ourselves apart that's
why we put so much preparation into what
we do those of you who have watched Greg
Whiteley's reality TV show last chance
you already know that an athlete's
career can be ruined in the blink of an
eye contact sports are dangerous and
since football players constantly tackle
each other injuries can ensue well Greg
Whitely is back and this time he's
created cheer a six-episode ducky series
that highlights the dangers of
competitive cheerleading although
cheerleaders aren't tackling each other
down while in heavy gear they do perform
jumps that can end in disaster
when cheerleaders are catapulted into
the air they place their trust and
well-being in the hands of their
teammates failing to catch your fellow
teammate after you send them soar in the
air is a huge mistake that can result in
severe injury so for this reason
cheerleaders are punished whenever they
drop someone Monica Aldama has a very
simple rule to keep her kids in check if
you drop a girl drop and give me 50
pushups whoever thought of chucking
someone into Aarons you know
that person is psychotic when you're in
the public eye images everything why you
post online can get you into trouble and
so can posting about your religious
views and political opinions receiving a
cheer scholarship at Navarro college
isn't an easy thing to accomplish these
selected were chosen because they were
the best and they have loads of
potential but in truth it doesn't matter
how amazing a navarro college
cheerleader is because if they can
uphold a wholesome image online
Monica Aldama will have to send them
packing while posting pictures of
yourself and a bikini won't land you in
hot waters with the school posting
pictures of yourself sipping margaritas
by the full sure will the rules are
pretty simple don't feed into the party
culture promote your team at all costs
and don't upload videos of you smoking
or vaping professional cheerleaders have
to keep their social media accounts
under wraps
talking badly about a teammate or coach
on youtube or snapchat can get you
kicked off the team - and so can posting
about that funny party last night only
to show up to practice tired and
nauseous you are a freaking nebari
cheerleader is definitely a privilege
you would think that cheerleaders would
be instructed to tie their hair back in
a high ponytail after all having your
hair in a ponytail can stop it from
flying into your face while performing
jumps but that's not what your hair is
all about while about 90% of the sport
revolves around athletics the other 10%
orbits around looking the part
cheerleaders who show up to games with
inadequate hair will be sent home
immediately sure they could fix their
hair backstage but that's not the point
the point is that professional
cheerleaders should always come prepared
and there's only one hairstyle that goes
with the Navarro college uniform this
hairstyle consists of tying the top half
of one's hair back with a bow and
letting the bottom half cascade down
your back in other words female
cheerleaders are instructed to fashion
their hair in a half up half down style
oh and don't forget about the bow the
color of the bow changes from
competition to competition and the girls
on the squad have to match with their
teammates or else
[Applause]
mónica Aldama has served as the head
coach of neurologists to your team for
over two decades over the years she
garnered tons of experience which has
helped her coached the team to
perfection Monica has a deep love for
every student on her team which is why
she's extra hard on them
she knows that at any moment a mistake
can happen that ruins their cheer career
for good and she won't let that happen
Monica has a saying that is so crisp it
was used in Netflix's official trailer
and it also happens to be a rule that
she swears by you keep going until you
get it right then you keep going until
you get it wrong
this statement shines a light on why the
Navarro team has managed to bring home
so many titles
Monica's coaching method does not leave
room for mistakes she wants her kids to
feel as confident performing a basket
toss or a pop-up tuck as they are
speaking their native tongue I have lots
of anxiety and I don't want them to see
how nervous I really am do you love
finding out about the ins and outs of
cheerleading then subscribe to the
things for more videos like this one and
be sure to enable notifications by
clicking on the bell we post daily
videos about your favorite shows on
Netflix and Disney Plus if you're
watching on your phone or tablet go into
your youtube settings and switch on
notifications this way you'll be the
first to know when we post a new video
now let's get back to the competitive
world of cheerleading keep watching to
find out which rule can turn your
teammates into your worst enemies it's
easy to forget that the Navaro cheer
team attends classes at the college this
is especially true since the team spends
nearly every waking moment thinking
about cheerleading or practicing their
routines according to Greg Whitely the
cheer team practices about three to four
times longer than the football team this
can make keeping your GPA where it needs
to be that much more challenging but
that's a rule the team can't ignore
since many of them are attending college
on a scholarship letting their grades
slip just isn't an option failing
classes and exams can get you kicked off
the team in the blink of an eye
no matter how talented you are at
cheerleading after all you need to
attend Navaro college to earn a spot on
the cheer team some cheer lovers have
admitted to taking a few classes at the
college
so that they can continue cheering under
Monica damas watchful eye
that's just how amazing she is today
it's about you it's about you stepping
it up okay this team is it you don't
need anything or anybody else while a
cheerleaders behavior ends their skill
set are two very different things
these worlds collide when you're a part
of the Navarro College to your team
while being respectful online is of the
utmost importance the same goes for how
people can port themselves in public
today anyone can whip out their phone
and videotape you and they can upload
the video online and unfortunately for
athletes this can put a stop to their
career the cheerleaders at Navarro
college note this all too well
which is why Monica instructs them to
act like a saint in public screaming
matches fights and poor behavior can
cost them their spot on the team and so
can being inebriated in public it's a
cheerleader stop to maintain the team's
good stature tons of professionals have
lost their jobs after a video of them
acting on public surfaced on the
Internet and the same goes for
cheerleaders lifting each other up but
that's our job that's why cheerleaders
were invented cheerleaders are no
different than the rest of us they face
daily hardships that make getting out of
bed in the morning a hard thing to do
some come from baffling backgrounds that
can make it challenging to put a smile
on their face but that's a rule they
can't ignore performing daunting
routines the cheerleaders job but so is
keeping a smile on their face while
being thrown into the air learning how
to perform jaw-dropping routines
wouldn't be as impressive of
cheerleaders look terrified and for that
reason they always have to have their
game face on it doesn't matter if
they're going through a breakup or if
they're fighting a cold or mourning the
loved one smiling during their
performances and acting like puffed up
athletes is a must
sure their smiles might dwindle with
their learning and new routine but once
they have it down pat they have to
rehearse their routines while keeping an
upbeat attitude about them if they
neglect to do this they'll fail to earn
a spot on the competition mat you have
to capitalize on that opportunity
because it's not always open in life
don't let the title of Netflix's
docu-series misguide you while cheer
might come off as a peppy series it's
anything but
cheerleading is a precarious sport that
results in injury more often than not in
fact most cheerleaders have broken a
bone or two during their professional
career if the Netflix series has taught
us anything it's that cheerleaders
suffered numerous injuries by practicing
their challenging routines and Navaro
coach Monica Aldama
knows this better than anyone she's been
coaching the team for over 20 years and
she seen tons of people suffer brutal
injuries in a matter of seconds you
would think that football players suffer
more injuries than their cheerleaders
but that isn't always the case
cheerleaders are one mistake away from
breaking their necks and backs
Monica constantly has to remind her kids
to watch their knees as a strain II can
knock someone in the face resulting in a
broken nose if someone gets hurt they
need to come clean asap Monica isn't
about to let her cheerleaders push
through the pain this could turn a
simple injury into a grave one while
putting the rest of the team at risk
yeah go to the beginning you would think
that keeping your record clean was an
easy thing to do but this rule has
proved itself to be the most difficult
one to follow
although the cheerleaders at Navarro
college spend most of their time
practicing routines and studying their
college kids through and through anyone
who gets arrested be it for drinking in
public stealing from a store are
cheating on a test will get kicked off
the team just like that this includes
getting into trouble with campus
security felonies like fighting
possession driving under the influence
and everything in between can results in
an immediate expulsion we don't want to
spoil cheer for you guys so we won't but
one cheerleader had to learn this rule
the hard way let's face it we're all
here to win so if you're not giving your
best and the cheerleaders at Navarro
college go above and beyond to get
noticed by their coach they want to
secure a spot on the competition team
but this isn't a straightforward process
Monica starts by coaching a total of 40
cheerleaders only to pick 20 of her best
members to compete at the NCAA college
nationals in Daytona they only have two
minutes and 15 seconds of matte time to
impress the judges and choosing the
right athletes is something that Monica
excels at but there's one role her team
would never
forget your spot in the competition
isn't guaranteed until you step foot on
the mat knowing that only one half of
the cheerleading squad will compete mix
the sport that much more competitive and
anything from a bad hair day to a
last-second injury can cost you your
spot on the mat now that you know about
all the hard work sweat and dedication
that goes into cheerleading
how has your view of the sport changed
have you already been judged watched the
six episode docu-series cheer tell us in
the comments ten strict rules Netflix's
to your squad has to follow thanks for
watching the things give this video a
big thumbs up and subscribe for more
we'll catch you next time
you